hello my name is Debra Pratt I was born
and raised in Chicago Illinois I have
lived in Los Angeles for 25 years and I
am a screenwriter how long have I been a
screenwriter I have been a screenwriter
well concentrated for about the past
five years I started in teleplays and
television and have since decided that I
needed more latitude and more freedom in
my writing so I am now writing
screenplays Helen's been working on my
current script I have been working on my
current script I wrote it as a short
film about nine years ago and then I
recently within the past year rewrote it
into a feature-length film the most
current one is called hearts where why
did I write it I wrote it because I
wanted to talk about women and women
dealing with abuse through a story of
friendship I wanted to explore what the
system does to women and
why is it why it is important for us to
tell these kinds of stories that a lot
of women who defend themselves and kill
their husbands go to jail for
self-defense so it's a great courtroom
drama I don't think I've seen it before
it's an homage to Aaron Sorkin's a few
good men for whatever only not the
military why haven't you put on this
script because it's a great story and
incredible characters and there's a lot
of tension to it and truth to it an
opportunity to explore a great woman's
story and interracial relationships it
works on multiple levels and I'm very
passionate about it and it just needs to
be told so I wrote it one lesson
screenwriting has taught me to be honest
when I write the world that I write
about and I write a variety of things
from science fiction to action-adventure
to drama and some comedy I find that if
I put myself on the page in as many
characters as I can I find that there is
truth and the writing and the dialogue
and the scenarios and the choices that
are made so truth is the greatest lesson
that I've learned and don't be afraid to
expose yourself through your characters
when do I write I'm a morning writer
although if I'm on deadline oh right for
eight hours and time is irrelevant
I like writing in the morning because
it's most quiet and I can be most
focused and the phone doesn't ring and
most people don't want things early in
the morning so early in the morning what
are my screenwriting goals to have the
support this industry and to reach out
to the fanbase that I want to touch and
entertain and enlighten to understand
the process of getting from the page to
the screen in a way that allows me
success and opportunity to keep writing
to do the other films that I've written
and to direct so I write with an
ultimate goal of directing I started in
television as a staff writer I have
moved into producing an executive
producing and now I want to expand my
horizons into screenplays and future
films
tell us about your screenwriting career
do you mean as in the future how do I
see my screenwriting career my
screenwriting career is the gift of
writing in the sense that I can write
whatever I want whenever I want and
that's the freedom of being a writer my
screenwriting career to get my films
made I have to write a lot of cases for
the system for commercial 'ti and if I'm
clever and if I am dedicated enough I
can
do that and also make an opportunity to
tell a great story about incredible
characters and speak of a universal
truth something that we need to talk
about if you you look at the films from
last year and what happened last night
on the Academy Awards spotlight was an
important issue related film the big
short was a huge issue related film
Carol was a big issue related film I
love films historic films and
understanding the history of film I went
to AFI and really studied the history of
filmmaking and I love films for that
reason I love what they're capable of
and I love how they can touch people and
empower people and inspire people and I
think as a filmmaker and it starts on
the page first the stone of a page it's
not gonna be anyplace else and that's
about my screenwriting career if I get
the opportunity to make my movies as a
director and a producer I'm gonna have a
great screenwriting career Thank You
Deborah Pratt I look forward to speaking
with you soon